yo you better get your hands off me dog
you almost could be yeah you better back
up before you get smacked [ __ ] up oh
what's that you got a gun now
that's coop always that what we gonna do
we gonna rob people now is that what we
do kids okay take my wallet take my I
don't need this
Oh what is going on you too often ask
the question that I sparked my interest
and your debut I just grabbed a little
bit well miss subscriber laughs do I
know how to fight um uh hunkered up with
this I'm a little [ __ ] I'm not afraid
you a minute when it comes down to this
fighting Oh No thank you sucker
my neighbor said they had a little money
it's called when [ __ ] goes down David
ain't around I know but you're thinking
already Oh real talk you ain't down for
your voice in let me ask you something
brother
I got it messed up like a little [ __ ]
for us to be friends huh is that how
fresh it works nowadays matter of fact
how did you expect me to do [ __ ] you
already knew before [ __ ] went down then
I'll carry a bottle of pepper spray and
a rape whistle yeah that's right [ __ ]
potatoes on me I'll call the cops in a
second I'll give up that's why I'm
sitting with that person my dad he dosed
Antonia are you talking about the
six-year-old girl over there what does
it happen are you all dressed to a nap
to finish y'all a system David so tips
on fighting
so y'all ready know what it is LG after
let's get it that gal tip number one if
you're big like me this work about 50%
of time 100% of time what scare your
opponent by making big threats what kind
of clips you ask always go with crazy
this have to be true no make [ __ ] up
puts a little bit rubbing metal tablets
I don't know if we shut down that baby
all day cuz go don't [ __ ] don't know
[ __ ]
don't what's that no you better get you
all some it [ __ ] I picture back in
Africa
well I'm sorry what was that this mother
who's crazy is that legal
damn number two if you know for a fact
that he ain't it does just say you got a
gun but so here what every time [ __ ]
goes down I always say have a gun now I
don't own one out on the line I've ever
didn't your story about a year or so
back I moved into my cousin's house and
when I was at my cousin's house the very
first night that I was unpacking my car
got broken into it was about 4 a.m. and
I was unpacking my stuff out the room
and suddenly I hear glass shattering it
was a dude in a Honda Civic Asian guy
breaking into my car for some reason the
first thing on your foot hey back what I
Bobby grab peace not only deaf until I
had a gun I also pretended that somebody
was with me my cut the book but it was
like uh did you just say grab the piece
huh no understand it I was like you know
where's the p-set because we live in
such a violent world tip number three
del out an area in the local vicinity
that you know is ghetto after that
yellow a whole bunch of names numbers
and add voices and see if that works but
you don't copy [ __ ] for five eight nine
Wedgwood Street extra bucks for a soft
little [ __ ] see what's good sprinkles
gogo tip number four if all else fails
[ __ ] yourself a cry stop crying
have I done it a few times none of your
business I found out the thugs you don't
like to smack people you know with
boogers coming up their nose a couple
cry man don't talking Jessup yo hey boys
hey big boy so five anyways it all
series is the best situation to get in
is to not fight it up I know that sounds
corny but honestly it's not worth it I
don't know what you thinking but I want
to look like a little [ __ ] but what
does it matter if you look like a little
[ __ ] to a bunch of thugs they going
anywhere so stay classy people and if
none of these tips work then you better
get on your knees and get ready to suck
up that was gonna say something out song
y'all nasty ooh if later on tonight I
ask you to be my girlfriend
right
me
negative na'toth writes what are you
Spanish why people scrapping means
fighting is this man you see is this a
white people fight I don't know I don't